quand on fait une émission de télé assez
jeune dans sa carrière pas toujours
facile de l'assumer toute sa vie ce que
prouve une fois encore l'interview de
jérémy amelin candidats de la saison 5
de star academy 7 ans après son passage
jérémy amelin est aujourd'hui encore
chanteur interviewé par france tv
l'ancien candidat est revenu sur son
aventure au château et ne garde pas un
très bon souvenir de son passage
notamment des pratiques de la production
on nous réveillait la nuit pour aller en
salle d'interview on nous disait bon tu
peux me dire ça et ce sont des choses
qu'on avait dix ans salle csa
et quand les candidats ne souhaitait pas
répondre aux questions des journalistes
ou aller dans leur sens jérémy assure
que la production employer des
techniques bien particulière il allume
les lumières dans les chambres pour que
tes potes ne puissent pas dormir et là
tes potes viens de te dire vas-y répond
aux questions disent qu'ils veulent
alors un ancien candidat de la star
academy ballon sur la production choqué
choqué oui non alors globalement vous
n'êtes pas choqué jean pascal est ce que
alors qu'un tas de choses à nous dire
là-dessus
alors j'ai fait j'ai participé à
l'émission avec lui et c'est vrai que
quand il a annoncé sa il a vraiment dit
des choses de manipulation de la
production qui s'était réveillée qu'on
leur force est à dire des choses étaient
vraies à qui sont vrais ou pas a priori
lui l'a confirmé et apparemment c'est
moi je trouve ça choquant parce que ça
veut dire que ce n'est plus déjà à la 5
de la télé-réalité c'est c'est un
scénario qui est écrit moi
personnellement ça m'a choqué parce que
ça fait ch il a vécu ou pas nous
franchement j'ai toujours été honnête
vous le savez on n'a jamais été guidés
est-ce que par la suite il a fallu non
nous a jamais réveiller en nous disant
il faut que tu n'y suis pas ce que vous
êtes arrivé avec votre spontanéité votre
naturel vous aviez pas encore tous les
codes au bout de la cinquième saison les
gens savent comment ça fonctionne mais
sa fausse alors le le concept moi ça m'a
choqué justement parce que je trouve que
ça remet en cause beaucoup de choses
alors c'est toi tu en penses quoi
mais j'ai du mal moi avec les gens qui
viennent cent cinquante ans plus tard
qui disent ah oui j'ai oublié il y avait
ça mais en fait non c'est trop tard
c'est soit la question qu'à ce moment là
aussi mais même si on lui pose la
question à ce moment là d'accord
peut-être mais c'est quand même ça s'est
passé a quand même presque 20 ans les
acéistes mais c'était presque pas né
moi j'ai du mal c'est la pression que
aujourd'hui veulent faire du pied gens
là veulent faire du buzz
juste pour être remarqué voilà pour dire
et magali je suis là tu peux me signer
ou non mais moi je le vois vraiment
comme ça je dans le sens où ils font du
buzz ils veulent être reconnus sur les
réseaux ils sortent tout et n'importe
quoi celui qui va par là vias de plus
vous le prendre et on n'est pas plus
proche que ça il m'a dit par rapport à
l'émission pour vous je pense qu'il est
plus peut-être pas un poids mais pas
pour faire de la pub mais pour il avait
besoin de le dire voilà les réseaux ou
la suite il est passé entre par magali
toi ça te rend dingue
il a fait une émission aujourd'hui donc
c'est qu'il veut c'est quand même se
montrer ce ne serait pas dans cette
émission de la tnt jambes raides calme
maintenant voilà maintenant excuse moi
tu as tout à fait raison aujourd'hui ces
buzz à tout prix voilà je veux buzz et
sur les réseaux je veux sortir du sale
comme ça je me fais remarquer
la presse fait du placement de produit
et c'est triste parce qu'en fait déjà
d'une c'est pas ce métier là qu'on veut
même pour le placement de produit ce
passage sur veut et deuxièmement je
trouve que c'est malheureux de cracher
dans la soupe qui est à nourri et qui
aujourd'hui fait que tu es là parce que
ce que tu n'avais pas ça eh ben on te
tue ne ferait petit exprimerait pas
aujourd'hui donc moi j'ai j'ai un
profond sentiment de dégoût pour les
gens qui déboîte les productions et les
chaînes après après coup parce que ben
peut-être que il ne correspond plus à
l'émission peut-être que ils ont besoin
de faire autre chose et dans la vie faut
avancer
je suis désolé mais feu il fait un peu
de temps aussi à ce qui est aujourd'hui
j'en ai ils sont vraiment forts match
que je connais plein moi les gens de
télé réalité et c'est des gens bien ça
des gens corrects mais c'est à cause de
ce genre de personnes là on a une image
je vais faire du buzz voilà
moi je les ai vécus et je pense
qu'effectivement les choses sont parfois
très orientée dans certaines conventions